the Joe Rogan experience what are you
gonna do next
cuz I tell you you're one of those dudes
you have to keep doing these things
once you've done two of these things
you're gonna keep doing these things
yeah I did a couple before that too um
but I think last time your advice to me
was stop stop yeah but you didn't listen
you know look like I'm passionate about
these things it's super fun I do them
because I like testing the edges of my
potential I like exploring different
places like I'd never like I said I'd
never wrote a boat before
and that kind of take this project on
and say you know I've done expeditions
before I've pushed my body and you know
deep and interesting ways but one of my
biggest curiosities is certainly about
the mind but you know particularly like
growth mindset can I say like I'm not a
rower but in the course of a year of
training I'm gonna train myself up get
on a team with some amazingly you know
accomplish water men and learn the
skills required to you know make this
crossing and it was cool to kind of
prove that out this year because I think
that that really applies across so many
things and I'm just a generally curious
person and I think I'll keep pushing
myself and pushing my body because
that's one of the things I love to do
but I think that curiosity throughout my
life is gonna be you know a lifelong
path of diving into sort of different
things and taking them on I think that
to me one of my biggest sadnesses on
things I like to say to people is like
you know people come to a certain point
in that their life and they're like you
know I'm I'm a lawyer or I'm good at
math or I'm terrible at art or like I
could never do comedy because I'm not
the funny one or I'm like you know these
limiting beliefs inside of us it's like
I could be like dude I've never wrote
ever in my life I'm you know thirty four
years old you know I've never wrote a
book but actually like but like doesn't
mean I can't learn now to row a boat
sounds pretty straightforward yeah
exactly how are could it be a little leg
action - what did you do to prepare for
it physically so the physical the
physical prep was was pretty cool I
don't know if you remember from last
time but I have this coach his name's
Mike McCaskill and he's just this
legendary guy he's you know done 5,800
pull-ups in 24 hours he's pulled a truck
across
valia yeah he's a total total legend and
he trained me up for America I mean I
came to him and I said hey look like I'm
not the most experienced polar explorer
I got to pull this 375 pounds sled like
what do you think how can you train me
up and he came up with such cool
training methodologies for that like he
had one of the things he had me doing
for Antarctica was he had me you know I
was doing planks with my hands in ice
buckets and you know as my heart rates
getting jacked up he's having me hold
that and all the sudden he's like
alright get out and I doing a wall sit
but now my feet are in the ice buckets
and he puts a weight plate on top of my
legs and he's like okay and then he
hands me these Legos and he's like solve
these Lego problems and until you don't
solve this Lego and build this little
like you know aircraft little Lego man
or whatever you know you can't get your
feet out of the ice bucket like what the
hell was going on but he's like look
you're gonna be in Antarctica your life
is going to depend on Utah you know
securing your tent right or tying down
the ropes properly or this and that the
other thing you're going to be cold your
hands are gonna be frozen you're gonna
be tired but you're gonna need your mind
your dexterity to be there yeah there's
that there's a picture of that of Mike
bringing me through that and so with the
row it was super cool to come to him
again and say like hey man like there's
no blueprint for this like there's no
blueprint for this there's no one that's
done a fully human power crossing of
Drake Passage before to the Antarctic
Peninsula like there's some ocean rowers
but this is different like how should we
prepare for this and Mike it's not like
he's like well I know everything about
ocean rowing but that same curiosity
that same growth mindset I trust his you
know sort of ability to train he's like
I don't know man like let's start
thinking through this and so in the gym
I mean we did all sorts of creative
things he brought the ice back he
started putting a rowing machine on BOSU
balls like half BOSU balls basically and
I'd start rowing you know didn't nor him
a rowing motion but he'd starts shaking
it around because basically the ocean is
gonna be moving me around so much so
just the rowing motion isn't gonna
prepare me for the lateral movements you
know the the lats the obliques you know
the all the kind of side-to-side
stability stuff then he took it one step
further which is he actually shows up at
my house knocks on my door at two
o'clock in the morning I think he had
pre-arranged it with my wife knocks on
the door he's like get up and I'm like
what that's happening he's like we're
going we're training right now and he
gets me he's got those BOSU balls but
now it's the middle of the night so I'm
sleep-deprived I'm kind of disoriented
now he's got me
on the BOSU balls and he had brought
these buckets of ice water so I'm rowing
this thing it's shaking around it's the
middle of night and he starts throwing
ice water on me and we're doing these
laps yeah Here I am
you know getting into this the yeah you
could check this out the Discovery
Channel did back this is training for
the Drake the impossible row episode 3
you could find it online Jay meets on
the Discovery Channel YouTube page
YouTube they have a whole playlist ok
yeah so there's 14 of these videos
training all the way through the whole
project discovery put them online
they're actually doing a feature-length
documentary this spring but yeah did you
do for rowing for the specific muscles
of rowing yourself did you lift weights
did you do rows did use a rowing machine
which used yeah so the rowing machine on
the BOSU balls that's like in the gym
also a lot of deadlift was really useful
and then a lot of stability stuff so
Mike would have me do certain things
like we'd have you know like a seated
row or something like that or more
thongs I thought that was the most
interesting because it was going to be
dis stable to the waves are usually
coming from and they change direction
but any given time they're coming
generally from one direction so you're
either leaning and really hard to your
left side you're leaning and really hard
to your right side that's a different to
the ocean rowing than just like a pure
river rowing and you know he would have
me basically like holding imagine like a
like a like a deadlift bar mm-hm and
then I'd have my eyes closed I'd be
holding it there and kind of an
isometric motion and then he would pull
the plate a light plate off one of the
sides and so I'd have to stabilize and
catch you know even my left side or my
right side so a lot of stabilization and
balance stuff and then the other piece
that was huge you know Mike you know
admittedly doesn't know a lot about
rowing specifically in terms of the
technique of rowing and the technique of
rowing is actually very specific and so
a friend of mine a guy named Chris wada
from Portland he I called him up and
he's like this champion rower collegiate
rower rowing coach and he took me out on
the Willamette River in Portland in a
single man like rowing scull so very
different than an ocean Robo ocean
robots a lot bigger different different
waves but he taught me on the river the
actual purity of the rowing motion so a
lot of the training and the physical
aspects I'm getting stronger was with
Mike and the mindset and the ice and all
the things we did there but certainly
the stuff that we did on the row on the
river in the Willamette with Chris was
huge for me to actually understand the
motion because
I just like you and you're like how hard
can it be just kind of push your arms
you know back and forth of it's a pretty
complicated motion it's a full-body
thing it's a coordinate it's a very
coordinated thing you know you're
powering out of different things and
certainly on river rowing you're having
to you know square it's called squaring
the blades and you know you've your pick
taking the blades out of the water and
you know turning them so they could
slide across the top and get back in and
glide and all that kind of stuff so
there's a lot there's a lot to the
motion and so it was a short period of
time I didn't take my first stroke in a
rowboat until July and in the in the in
the river and then August in the ocean
robot when we came together as a team
for the first time to train in Scotland
and then I was rowing across the Drake
in December so it was a pretty short
period of time to kind of learn learn
about rowing and get stronger but it was
a fun process to dive into something
completely new
[Applause]